what's going on is I've got this little
3x3 grid of values that's marching along
our original image and if we zoom in
each one of those values is 1 nth and
what I'm doing at each iteration is
multiplying each of those values by the
corresponding pixel that it sits on top
of and of course in computer science we
think of colors as little vectors of
three values representing the red green
and blue components when I multiply all
these little values by 1 nth and I add
them together it gives us an average
along each color Channel and the
corresponding pixel for the image on the
right is defined to be that sum the
overall effect as we do this for every
single Pixel on the image is that each
one kind of bleeds into all of its
neighbors which gives us a blurrier
version than the original in the lingo
we'd say that the image on the right is
a convolution of our original image with
a little grid of values or more
technically maybe I should say that it's
the convolution with a 180° rotated
version of that little grid of
values